this episode is made possible by Wix
build your own professional website with
Wix by following the link below imagine
two people are having a disagreement one
of them mentions a peer-reviewed study
to support their position the other gets
angry and responds with something like
that's just your opinion and continues
to give his perspective without
providing any supporting evidence in
today's social and political climate
this type of argument is all too common
discussions devolve into shouting
matches because for some reason opinions
now seem to hold just as much weight as
actual facts in this episode we're going
to look at what's causing this problem
and whether there's anything we can do
to fix it but before we go any further
let's define the words fact truth and
opinion fact a piece of information
presented as having objective reality or
the quality of being actual a fact is a
bit of information that is objectively
and demonstrably accurate regardless of
one's feelings on the matter earth is
the third planet from the Sun and the
fifth largest in the solar system that's
a fact the Great Barrier Reef is the
largest living structure on earth that's
a fact
these are verifiable statements that
have been shown to be accurate or true
truth is defined as the body of real
things events and facts or the property
of being in accord with fact or reality
the word truth hinges on a statement
being a verifiable fact an accurate
representation of reality so if somebody
were to tell you one of the
aforementioned facts they would be
telling you the truth
opinion beliefs stronger than impression
and less strong than positive knowledge
or a view judgment or appraisal formed
in the mind about a particular matter
opinions while sometimes based on
knowledge of facts are generally
unsupported and are the product of one's
feelings an example of an opinion would
be pineapple pizza is the best so a fact
can be proven whereas an opinion cannot
because it's an untestable expression of
one's feelings these definitions should
give us a pretty good understanding of
the hierarchy and relationship between
facts opinions and truth here's the
problem it's somebody's version of the
truth not the truth he didn't have a a
conversation this truth I don't be to go
like no it isn't truth truth isn't truth
you're saying it's a falsehood and
they're giving Sean Spicer our press
secretary gave
alternative faxed that's very different
from how we just defined these terms and
that's intentional most people watching
someone say truth isn't truth would say
wait yes it is but if they repeat it
often enough and loudly enough slowly
those in possession of actual facts are
left powerless as others begin to say
well that's your version of the truth I
don't believe that when facts are
stripped of their power all that's left
is people yelling at each other from one
side or the other it becomes a near
insurmountable challenge just to get to
the baseline where both parties can
agree yes these are the facts and go
from there there have always been
arguments based upon disagreement over
what's most accurately reflected in
reality but over the last few years
things seem to have gotten really bad
where did this problem come from I'll
give you a hint you're using it right
now the Internet as amazing and useful
as it can be has given bad ideas that
means to spread and multiply and infect
people that normally wouldn't be
affected by such harmful rhetoric the
Internet is impartial and driven by
algorithms it doesn't care what
information is being distributed nor
does it restrict the creation of
factually inaccurate content in fact
these simple algorithms reward easily
digestible viral content think of it
like the evolution of a parasite online
groups communicate and slowly build a
giant straw man of the opposing position
the weaker ideas don't catch on and die
off and the stronger more inflammatory
ones become more common these parasites
are shared on Facebook and other social
media where suggestible people absorb
them and share them again giving these
bad ideas access to exponential growth
this is all too common leading up to and
ever since the 2016 presidential
election more misleading or flat-out
false news stories have been shared than
real news when over 60% of US adults get
at least some of their news from social
media you can see how this could become
a huge problem but what can we do about
this trend are we stuck in a post truth
society for good it's hard to say for
certain but fixing the problem will be a
huge challenge it's much easier to fool
people than it is to convince them
they've been fooled we seem to be
creeping inexorably toward an Orwellian
future where truth is defined by those
in power take for example this quote
from Orwell's 1984 the party told you to
reject the evidence of your eyes and
ears it was their final most essential
command
what you're seeing and what you're
reading is not what's happening on the
bright side many people are aware of
this alarming trend of conflating
opinions and worse lies with facts and
the truth after Kellyanne Conway made
her remark about alternative facts sales
of 1984 went through the roof a large
portion of the population is aware of
the shift in discourse and we have the
means to bring it back to normal
each of us has the very human tendency
to go out and find information that
agrees with how we think it's our
responsibility to acknowledge that
tendency and do some research to
ascertain whether that information is
accurate we as a society need to come to
an agreement that there is a reality and
that there are true and accurate facts
and that truth facts and reality should
always take precedence over opinion on a
personal level we need to separate
ourselves from our opinions and not
immediately get defensive when we hear
something that contradicts one of our
beliefs on the contrary we need to be
more open to replacing our opinions with
those that are more firmly rooted in
reality in fact at the end of the day
most people either don't have the time
or don't care enough to do any research
to validate their opinions this is a
problem but it's an understandable one
maybe the solution is to take a good
long look at how the internet functions
and see if there's some way to
algorithmically detect false information
to prevent the spread of these parasites
of course any attempt to regulate the
flow of information on the internet
could be seen as an attack on freedom of
expression or worse outright censorship
but we have to be willing to entertain
potential solutions to this crisis of
truth we're currently experiencing it
will be a struggle but if each of us can
commit to being willing to examine our
own beliefs and only agree to have a
discussion with others on the basis of
verifiable fact and opinions based on
those facts I think we can overcome this
challenge and become better together
speaking of facts and opinions here are
a couple more fact I recently built my
own website with Wix opinion it was a
really easy and enjoyable experience
with Wix you can build amazing
professional websites for just about any
application Wix can handle any project
you throw at it whether you want to host
videos share your photo gallery book
clients sell products or just about
anything else you could ever want
whether you need a professional website
for your own personal use or for
e-commerce music hotels or restaurants
Wix does all the heavy lifting like
hosting custom domains
Marketing and more allowing you to focus
on the creative side of things you have
total creative freedom over your
websites allowing for limitless
possibilities and you don't even have to
be a web designer Wix caters to everyone
regardless of skill level whether you're
a novice business owner or seasoned
website builder so if you want to build
your very own professional website visit
Wix by following the link below
[Music]